there's coffee it's really good to see
you this morning
let's start shall we with what we may be
expecting to hear from from the prime
minister tomorrow i mean i don't know
how much detail you can go into
but it does feel
that we're
it does feel that we're going to be
seeing quite a significant change to the
way things have been done in the past
well i think it's fair to say that uh
when we had a variety of regulations we
said we'd go back to parliament every
six months to see if those regulations
were still necessary but also some of
the ideas that we wanted to consider and
are still part of the toolbox like the
vaccine passports again we said we were
considering bringing these uh items in
but it's important that the government
uh that we look at exactly what benefits
that will bring and
right now the health secretary indicated
although we haven't made the formal
decision uh that he does not think that
it's necessary for the vaccine passports
to be introduced by the end of the month
uh but the prime minister will be
setting out tomorrow a lot more of the
detail of uh the the road map ahead
preparing for winter presumably the key
words in what you were just saying there
were for
right now for the time being
isn't it just the case that all of these
things lock down mask wearing social
distancing working from home they all
remain options that are on the table for
the government i think that's fair but
it's our clear intention recognizing the
success of the number of vaccinations
that have happened including
particularly amongst young people where
there's been a really good take-up over
the summer that we want to do things
which we consider only necessary to
tackle the transmission of risk and the
impact it has on the nhs so it's really
good news that we are seeing the success
of the vaccine so far so having done the
jobs we want to continue to try and get
people into jobs and that's why we're
investing even more in infrastructure
over the next decade too sure but you
could be forgiven if you picked up the
papers this morning that the decisions
on these things were were set in stone
and just on just on in terms of the kind
of the the chaos that there was in terms
of vaccine passports we were told last
week by the vaccines minister that they
were a reality and that they would be
introduced yesterday speaking uh
speaking to sky the health secretary
said i'm not here today to rule it out
then in the taxi journey that he took
over to the bbc he performed a u-turn
many people would say that's exactly
what she'd do if you're getting a taxi
to the bbc but clearly there is some
mixed messaging here
well i i don't know about the sequencing
yesterday um what i do know is that when
i sat on the cabinet committee several
months ago where we discussed uh looking
into vaccine passports yes there was an
indication that we would be minded to
bring that in towards the end of
september but we will review it at the
right time and as i say that formal
decision will be made and
the outcome of that announced uh but um
all the indications are from the health
secretary is that we do not need to
introduce the vaccine passports at the
end of the month uh you know there's
been good consideration of the
ups and downs of how you'd implement it
and similar
and i'm conscious that uh as i say the
number of vaccinations has shot up again
over the summer and that's great news
pcr tests though for travelers the
traffic light system is it fair for me
to assert that those are things that
could be going pretty soon
well i'm only aware of what the health
secretary said yesterday about his
consideration of where that might be
heading i think it's important again to
just make sure all the tires literally
been kicked to make sure
uh all the effects that we were looking
into for example the spread of the
different variants they've been picked
up by doing the detailed pcr tests
that's why we've been able to respond
but i'm conscious right around the world
again as we've seen the number of
vaccinations increase thus far some of
the more limited variants that have
risen have not been spreading right
around the world apart from the delta
against which we are well protected
clearly the nighttime industries will be
will be very pleased if the vaccine
passport scheme is is going to be part
it for the time being at least but i do
wonder what you make of you know for
example the premier league we've seen
some very very big clubs manchester
united amongst them that are introducing
if not mandatory checks on your vaccine
status then spot checks on people coming
into the ground i mean what would the
government say to them to carry on as
they are doing or they should they be
scrapping it in the same way the
government is well i think uh it's
sensible of um organizations employers
to do the checks they think are
necessary in order to protect public
health uh the difference is whether the
government was going to require vaccine
passports but right around the country
people will be going into their places
at work or other areas and they are
already being asked that sort of
activity have you got you two jabs and
similar in order to continue to try and
protect recognizing we still have a high
number of infections in this country on
a daily basis and we still want to keep
to trying to reduce that it's news
that's broken this morning so you may
not be aware but valeneva who are in
line to provide us with what 190 million
doses of their vaccine their stage three
of the clinical process at the moment
that contract has been terminated what
why is that i don't know the answer to
that right we'll hopefully get some
clarity on that a little bit later on in
the day but let's move to to what you're
here to discuss today which is of course
the the investment 650 billion pounds
worth of an investment in getting people
back to work just explain a little bit
about it and where that money is going
to be spent well we've seen um a variety
of ways the money will be spent whether
it's aspects of infrastructure
continuing supporter
but i think a more tangible element for
our your viewers would be two and a half
billion pounds to go into rebuilding
your schools or where repairs are needed
there i'm conscious that uh we expect
that to include about 425 000 jobs being
created so we continue to make sure our
plan for jobs which we believe is
working but how we continue to invest in
that so we can help people not only get
back into work but to get on in work and
to increase their take-home pay and that
really matters to us how do you justify
a conservative assertion that you are
committed to getting people back into
work with removing the 20 pounds uplift
universal credit well the 20 pound
uplift was specific to recognize the
shock that happened particularly for
people newly coming into benefits
of what happened with coronavirus
we do want to make sure that people as i
say are getting aspects of more training
on skills uh there are i think there's
been over 80 000 apprenticeship starts
helped by the incentive we've given by
employers to take people on over 60 000
young people are in kickstart but
overall we're seeing employment rise
month after month after month and we
want to continue that uh that people
getting in but also things like the
lifetime skills guarantee helping them
get a paid better paid job even more
straightforward question why are we
getting rid of the 20 pounds uplift
because it was a temporary measure
recognized for the extent of the
that's not an answer i mean saying that
it was a temporary measure you could
carry on with it if it was proved to be
working effectively it has been proved
working effectively well the the in
terms of uh you talk about working
effectively it was there is a an element
there to protect people particularly
those initially coming into benefits for
the first time we want to make sure we
make the shift into all about plan for
jobs and it's the ongoing investment in
that uh where we're seeing people get
back into work and we want people to get
on and work i mean this was this was the
argument you gave i think actually on
this program back in july when when we
spoke last about this that you know it's
all about getting people back into work
but this this is an in-work benefit
correct a third of people who are on it
are in work a third of people who are on
it basically we're playing around with
the numbers slightly here but a third of
people are are looking for work you know
are you entirely happy with this yes uh
we made this decision earlier in the
year the chancellor announced it in the
budget and that's why we're building up
the update to the plan for jobs to make
sure that as we see the end of the
furlough scheme so the support that's
happened there as we see the end of the
other support schemes that we've put in
place during this time of covid that we
accelerate our plan for jobs how does
taking a thousand pounds away from some
of the lowest
some of the poorest people in this
country how does that help them get back
into work well it was a temporary stop
gap as i've pointed out for people um
the uplift was done it made it in line
with the statutory sick pay the basic
pay that people could have if they were
out of work
for other reasons
but i'm conscious that we want to keep
working with our now 27 000 work coaches
around the country we've got over 200
extra job centres supporting people
getting to work but also to progress in
work as well 660 000 people according to
unite the union 660 000 key workers will
have a negative impact on their bank
balance as a result of this the joseph
ryan tree foundation says half a million
more people being faithful being faced
being pulled into poverty including 200
000 children citizens advice are warning
that a third of people in universal
credit will end up in debt when the
extra payment is removed all of those
taken together and you tell me that you
personally are happy to see this go well
if i think about the 20 pounds up week
that's just about two hours of national
minimum wage that's why we are working
through our work coaches with people
on low pay who may well be in work about
what we can do to help them get more
hours or indeed to get the skills in
order to get a higher paid job we've
already lifted the national minimum wage
so it's about 60 of median earnings 700
000 people being dragged into poverty
as i've pointed out well there's an
element we can get into discussion about
how poverty metrics are done as whether
they're uh relative measures and all the
other things the point is
there are definitely vacancies out there
we are there with 27 000 work coaches to
help people as i say get into but also
get on in work and that's what really
matters as well the progress that we can
help people get on and work let's let's
just take all of this together you know
we're saying it cut to the universal
credit uplift we're seeing an increase
in next national insurance contributions
we're seeing plans to freeze the income
tax at personal allowance
labor and you can you can challenge the
figures they say this will cost ordinary
workers social care workers nurses like
a thousand pounds a year more than that
now you may dispute the figures but
you're not going to sit there and tell
me that people are going to be better
off as a result of all those changes
well i'm conscious that it's about 15 of
the top earners who will pay for half of
the total revenues of the new national
insurance levy from next year but
there's other all of the sorts of
support that we do put in to try and
help people if i think about the six
billion pounds that is spent on child
care on average that's about 5 000
pounds per family that we put in there
to help them support with with those
other measures so there's a variety of
ways that government tries to help
families in order to be more prosperous
as well as structural elements like
continuing to increase the national
living wage but again you're not telling
me that people are going to be better
off as a result of the next change the
income tax freeze
and indeed that's what we're talking
about today the universal credit uplift
well i'm what i'm saying is that uh in
terms of aspects of jobs for those
people who only work a certain number of
hours we'll be seeing what we can do to
help them perhaps increase that number
of hours but also uh recognizing that we
want to help them get a higher wage
and that's important things like
the 650 billion pounds the 425 000 jobs
for that there's a real opportunity for
people to upskill and we're seeing that
coming through
away from your brief but but one of your
colleagues around the cabinet table and
pretty patel has once again been found
out to have been holding private
meetings with what in this occasion with
a billionaire of her acquaintance
without informing officials until after
the fact this was in essence what she
got sacked for before when she was
international development secretary when
can we expect her resignation well i
don't know the details of what you set
out uh what i'm aware of that sometimes
people you do end up meeting people um
perhaps by accident and you have a
conversation the important thing is she
passed away
that's the whole point of this story she
arranged a meeting took place in a hotel
it was coming you know one of the things
if you are not there with the private
secretary is that you pass the
information on to the officials
and then it's dealt with by the private
office uh it's um i know my own
experience you sometimes do see people
as long as you pass on the information
that's what matters uh to make sure that
the civil servants have the record and
they can declare that in the appropriate
way shouldn't that declaration be made
in advance of a meeting and not after it
potentially when someone finds out that
you've been having a meeting and you
rush to give the permanent sector a
phone call we'll say i don't know now
the precise details of what you're
referring to uh i'm i've
seen met somebody actually while i was
on holiday and didn't know them at all
but it turns out they were a supplier to
uh dwp so again i share the fact that by
chance at somebody's party i met
somebody who was there so it's those
sorts of things where
i don't say i don't know the details are
pretty uh but it's important we just
make sure it's transparent in that
regard with our civil servants and they
can use the information accordingly you
are the very vision of probity uh terese
coffee good to have you on the program
thanks